was wissen wir über den ersten
zugelassenen impfstoff schwerwiegende
nebenwirkungen traten nicht gehäuft auf
im vergleich zu ungeimpften waren
geimpfte häufiger einige tage lang in
ihrem alltag beeinträchtigt
zum beispiel durch schmerzen an der
einstichstelle schmerzen des kopf also
kopfschmerzen oder fieber dies
verschwand jedoch wieder
wir wissen über die impfung dass wir uns
in einem hohen maße davor schützen kopf
19 zu erkranken
wir wissen auch dass der m rna im stoff
unserer gene nicht verändert die mrsa
gelangt nicht in den menschlichen zellen
kern und wird somit nicht teil der
menschlichen erbanlagen und wir wissen
auch dass bei der entwicklung und
zulassung keine abstriche bei der
überprüfung der wirksamkeit und
sicherheit gemacht wurden
die impfung wurde an ausreichend vielen
menschen getestet um nebenwirkungen zu
erkennen auch solche die verspätet also
ein bis zwei monate danach oder nur
selten auftreten wie bei anderen
impfungen auch können sehr seltene
nebenwirkungen in zulassungsstudien
nicht sicher ausgeschlossen werden daher
wird dadurch das paul-ehrlich-institut
das auftreten von dem wirkung
fortlaufend überwacht die entwicklung
und zulassung war schneller
weil verschiedene prozesse gleichzeitig
anstatt hintereinander liefen weil wir
auf frühere entwicklungen zurückgreifen
konnten und weil weltweit in nie
dagewesener form zusammen gearbeitet
wird wurde und viel geld zur verfügung
stand was wissen wir noch nicht über den
ersten impfstoff wir wissen noch nicht
ob die impfung nicht nur das auftreten
einer erkrankung bei den geimpften
verhindert sondern auch die ansteckung
anderer menschen unsere erfahrung mit
anderen impfungen deuten jedoch darauf
hin und wir wissen nicht wie lange der
impfschutz anhält und wie gut die
impfung in besonderen risikogruppen wie
zum beispiel menschen mit
eingeschränkten immunsystem wirkt sicher
ist aber dass wir durch die impfung das
risiko verringern an kopf mit 19 zu
erkranken mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren